[Music]
on this Thursday night a powerful
memorial for George Floyd that's amazing
to me that he touched so many people
hearts the grief and the demands for
equal justice for all get your knees off
on NYX plus the growing pushback against
the US president president - instead of
unifying this country has divided it the
reality of systemic racism in Canada
it's disgusting
what's necessary to truly end it data on
Colvig 19 disputed the flaws and
failures with fast and furious research
when land cracks and then crumbles the
astonishing moment the sea swallows up
these homes and no longer hooped the
NBA's plan to bounce back
[Music]
verbal national with donna freezin
good evening and thanks for joining us
we begin tonight with some powerful
moments in Minneapolis the city where
George
Floyd an unarmed black man was pinned to
the ground by white police officers a
knee on his neck for eight minutes and
46 seconds his death leading to one of
the biggest outpourings of demands for
justice in American history
[Music]
at a memorial for George Floyd today
people stood praying weeping for the
same length of time Floyd lay on the
street saying I can't breathe and then
dying
[Music]
ah me Xing gray it was an outpouring of
grief and an outpouring of support for
Floyd's family all these people came to
see my brother and that's amazing to me
that he touched so many people hearts
and it was another powerful call for
justice not just for Floyd but everyone
like him
we cannot cooperate with injustice
we cannot cooperate with torture because
George Floyd deserve better than their
[Applause]
civil rights leader Reverend Al Sharpton
delivered the eulogy Taliban make
America great great for who and great
win we gonna make America great for
everybody for the first time all four
officers involved in Floyd's death have
been fired and charged the question
remains whether his death and the
outrage on the streets will lead to real
change
Jackson prosecco reports this moment of
change is being felt across every corner
of the US we come today inside the
Capitol building senators stood or took
a knee for eight minutes and 46 seconds
of silence the length of time George
Floyd was pinned to the ground in
Richmond Virginia once the center of the
American slave trade the governor
ordered the removal of a one hundred and
thirty year old statue of Confederate
General Robert Ely those monumental
shifts come as three former Minneapolis
police officers made their first court
appearance charged with aiding and
abetting Floyd's murder the fourth
officer involved derrick Chauvin the one
who put his knee on Floyd's neck is
charged with second degree murder
inside the increasingly fortified White
House dissent his building over the
president's heavy-handed approach to a
nation on the March defended Thursday by
the Attorney General at some
demonstrations there are extremist
agitators who are hijacking the protests
to pursue their own separate and violent
agenda Trump's former defense secretary
James maddest a scathing rebuke accusing
the president of purposely dividing
America and raising concerns about the
use of troops to police American
citizens for him to speak out and make
clear what the responsibilities of
leadership is all about I think was very
important for the military and for the
country the Marches themselves have
reached a critical juncture with no
clear sense of where they'll head next
in Washington hundreds held a die-in at
the Martin Luther King jr. memorial
before marching back to the White House
in Brooklyn a vigil and a march across
the Brooklyn Bridge across the country
there's a sense that the next steps and
coming days will cement this moment in
American history
Jackson prosecco Global News Washington
in the case of another unarmed black man
who was fatally shot in Georgia while
jogging a judge has now ruled there is
enough evidence to try three white
suspects for the murder of Ahmed R burry
the lead agent in the case testified
today that a white man was heard
uttering a racist slur as he stood over
armories body moments after killing him
the 25 year old was shot and killed on
February 23rd in Georgia and may video
was released showing the shooting
gregory McMichael a former police
officer and his son along with william
brian
have been charged with murder our buries
family says he was unarmed and just out
for a jog the US Justice Department is
weighing whether to late federal hate
crime charges reverend al sharpton has
been calling for changes in america for
decades the civil rights activist
believes a situation in the u.s. is at a
tipping point so to a lot of people
while speaking outside floyd service
today he made a reference to Prime
Minister Justin Trudeau's hesitation to
condemn President
from it's a new day the time has met the
moment of change in America and I'm
going to express that in my eulogy and
sent you from Canada I won't have a 21
second gap before I say what I have to
say across Canada there have been loud
calls to end racism and inequality -
Canada is not the United States but for
black Canadians and other racialized
communities racism is real and systemic
Abigail Beeman looks at what concrete
steps can be taken to end it we felt not
only belittled they felt villainized
demonized you know and put as the other
for his PhD Warren Clarke is studying
the experiences of young black men in
employment training programs he hears
about racism from them and he lives with
it it happens regularly enough where
it's it's disgusting since I moved to
Ottawa I've been pulled over by police
more than 20 times easily Clarke says
the whole system needs to be
acknowledged before policies can change
we live in a white settler colonized
nation-state everything we do what we
learned through education what we we how
we behave is through whiteness bringing
more voices to the table is one element
of systemic change Ross and King is the
first black city councilor in Ottawa
elected only last year I'm just going to
take a long period of time to address it
but the key is ensuring that we start to
address it and we start to really build
the tools that can address racism King
is the new council liaison for
anti-racism and ethno-cultural relations
and the city created an anti-racism
Secretariat focused on equality
everything from health to housing to
employment he's glad to see a
Secretariat at the federal level - and
elsewhere we're starting to see the
creation of these policy units that will
take steps to address systemic
discrimination this week the federal New
Democrat leader made specific calls for
action an end to over incarceration of
black and indigenous people and an end
to racial profiling
there could be clear legislation banning
that practice from the RCMP CSIS border
security the
government tells global news
discrimination in the public service is
illegal under the Charter and they've
been working to make changes to the
justice system to break the cycle of
criminality there is more that we need
to do as a country and as a government
and we will be acting will have more to
say about this Clark support Singh's
push but says the focus needs to be
broader than policing we need to
encourage people to get into
conversations that are going to make
them uncomfortable
Abigail Beeman Global News an Edmonton
man is speaking out about what happened
to him a police officer kneeled on his
neck during an arrest two years ago in
Edmonton the man's wife filmed it and
posted it to social media this week in
wake of George Floyd's death in police
custody she says seeing that brought
back bad memories the video is 14
seconds long you can see the officer
dropping his knee onto the back of the
man's head trying to restrain him today
Edmonton's police chief said that video
doesn't show what happened before and
after that moment it's very brief in
nature in it what was released may not
capture the eye just the activity prior
to the video that was posted and what we
believe to have occurred is is that the
the positioning of the leg or the across
the the subjects head was not any longer
than about 40 seconds Edmonton's police
chief says the man was resisting arrest
and that another video viewed by the
police shows the officer adjusting his
leg to what the chief calls a more
proper position shortly after that
moment a 26 year old indigenous woman
has been shot and killed by police in
New Brunswick it happened early this
morning in Edmundston that's about three
hours northwest of fredericton
Edmundston police say they were called
to the home for a wellness check police
say the responding officer was
confronted by a woman holding a knife
and making threats the officer shot the
woman and she was pronounced dead at the
scene
her family has identified her as Chantal
Moore she'd recently moved to Nebraska
crumby see an autopsy has been scheduled
the police have asked for an independent
review of
what happened New Brunswick RCMP are
providing investigative and forensic
support for that now to the pandemic as
much as we'd love to stop reporting on
kovat 19 the virus is still with us but
there are some encouraging signs about
the spread of the novel coronavirus in
Canada the latest federal data shows
overall cases are on the decline there's
a stark picture though of where the
virus is persisting over the last two
weeks 90 percent of all new cases in
Canada were in Ontario and Quebec in
particular the cities of Toronto and
Montreal have become hotspots for
transmission other provinces have seen a
drop in infections Canada's public
health officer warns that does not mean
now is the time for anyone to ease up on
physical distancing these models all
tell us that if we relax too much or too
soon the epidemic will most likely
rebound with explosive growth as a
distinct possibility
the latest federal projections predicted
by June 15th the death toll from kovat
19 in Canada could reach 90 400 people
at this point more than 7600 people have
died more than 600 new infections were
confirmed today the vast majority of
them are in Ontario and Quebec a number
of other provinces recorded no new
infections today New Brunswick recorded
its first death related to Cove at 19
today and it's connected to a doctor who
did not self isolate after returning
from Quebec an 80 year old man living at
this long-term care home near
campbellton has died of Kovan 19 the
home is dealing with an outbreak after a
staff member who is in contact with that
doctor working at the campbellton
Regional Hospital tested positive there
are 14 active cases in New Brunswick now
all of them in the campbellton area new
details have been released into Nova
Scotia's worst mass killing the RCMP say
the weapons the gunman used were
acquired illegally three came from the
United States a fourth he got illegally
in Canada and a fifth was taken from
constable Heidi Stephenson she was one
of the 22 people killed Ross Lord
reports on what else the RCMP revealed
it's become clear RCMP thought they had
the killer can
pained twice once at the scene of the
first murders and fires in Porter Peck
and again in the community of Glen home
early the next morning we actually
missed that gunman by minutes the gunman
went on to kill five more people before
police killed him since the RCMP is
previous briefing more than a month ago
there have been several allegations
police were tipped off about the gunman
years earlier including information he
wanted to kill a cop and that he was a
domestic abuser with an illegal weapons
collection and I called the RCMP and I
told them what happened former neighbor
Brenda Forbes says investigators ignored
her RCMP say they are searching their
records for her 2013 complaint a 2011
bulletin shared widely among police
agencies suggested the gunman was a
mentally unstable threat investigators
say an officer visited the gunman
several times however he didn't see
anything that would have caused him any
concern or allowed him to take any
further action the bulletin was
destroyed automatically two years later
investigators say a psychological
autopsy suggests the killer was an
injustice collector who held on to
conflicts turning them inward until
boiling over in rage they say his
actions might never be understood Ross
Laura Global News Halifax a natural
disaster caught on camera coming up the
horrifying moment homes are swept out to
sea
here's a reminder everything is
temporary a powerful landslide swept
part of a village in northern Norway
into the sea eight houses disappeared
within minutes everyone got out before
it happened the region is known for its
coastal landscapes and forests and the
landslides do happen they're rarely as
big as this one of the most
all-consuming searches for a missing
child appears after 13 years to have
reached an end Madeleine McCann was
three when she vanished from her bed in
the Portuguese resort town of praia
deluge while her British parents were
having dinner nearby no trace of her was
ever found but her parents never gave up
hope she was alive now as Mike Armstrong
reports German investigators have new
information that McCann's hoped they'd
never hear behind bars in this German
prison maybe answers to a mystery that
has stumped police for 13 years
according to reports the new suspect and
the disappearance of Madeleine McCann is
locked up in this institution police
aren't releasing his identity yet but
say their investigation is for suspicion
of murder
Venus adopts dismal Ottis from this the
state prosecutor says you can see that
we assume the girl is dead that is not
something authorities have said since
three-year-old Madeleine disappeared and
the reason for the change appears to be
the suspects background back in 2007 at
the time Madeleine was taken the suspect
lived in this home in Portugal by car
it's only a few minutes from the resort
where she'd been staying with her family
knife wounds on neck Henderson the
prosecutor says the 43 year old suspect
made a living committing crimes among
them breaking into hotels and holiday
apartments he also has multiple
convictions for sexual crimes including
the sexual abuse of children now police
have had hundreds of leads over the
years and several suspects but have
never found who took Madeleine from her
bedroom in this resort complex she had
been left in an apartment with two
siblings while her parents went for
dinner with friends at a nearby
restaurant when they went to check on
her she was gone
the McCanns issued a short statement
online thanking police for their
continued efforts and saying they still
hold out
hope of finding their daughter alive but
a family spokesperson says they are
realistic and at this point just want to
understand what happened they need to
know as they need to find peace German
British and Portuguese police are all
working this lead the releasing
photographs of the suspects vehicles and
asking anyone who thinks they know the
suspect to come forward because he's
behind bars they say there's nothing to
fear by going to police with information
Mike Armstrong Global News uncredible
influence still ahead how flawed that
ANCOVA 19 became the base for major
policies
a major study that cast doubt on the
safety of using hydroxychloroquine to
treat Kovac 19 patients and halted
global trials of the drug has now been
retracted three of its authors say data
used to produce the findings could not
be independently verified Heather Eurex
West explains when The Lancet published
a study in late May linking
hydroxychloroquine with an increased
risk of death for Kovac 19 patients
scientists around the world took notice
it caused people to stop doing what
they're doing in terms of high quality
science and to pause to delay the
high-quality science in order to try to
sort out whether this initial paper was
accurate or inaccurate the observational
study was the largest on the subject to
date but now three of the study's
authors say the patient data compiled by
Sergio sphere corporation could not be
independently verified we deeply
apologize to you the editors and the
journal readership for any embarrassment
or inconvenience that this may have
caused it's really unfortunate for
science dr. Michael Hill is the co-lead
of the Alberta Hope trial a
hydroxychloroquine study that was
suspended because of the research
published in The Lancet our safety
committee has reviewed everything and
said that look you know the tartlet are
looks totally safe and there's no
adverse effects with major adverse
effects worth hydroxychloroquine but the
delay has been costly for the study in
the time since the Alberta research was
suspended kovat 19 cases in that
province have dropped researchers aren't
sure if the Alberta Hope trial will
resume at all on Wednesday the World
Health Organization announced its
international clinical trial on the drug
had been cleared to resume the demand
for fast science has led to an
unprecedented amount of collaboration
among scientists worldwide but accuracy
isn't something that can be sacrificed
there has to be some evidence of
transparency and learning from this so
that mistakes like this aren't made in
the future because the stakes at this
point are high with both public health
and public trust on the line Heather
Erik's West Global News Calgary
Pook dreams come true next the NBA gets
a ticket to Disney World
it's the news basketball fans have been
waiting for the NBA could soon be back
in action
the league's Board of Governors approved
a plan to get teams on the court that
was Eric Sorenson explains many NBA
players have much more than basketball
on their minds this is where the NBA
hopes to crown a champion in 2020 Disney
World in Florida one location to isolate
the league from kovat 19 the players and
team personnel will go through health
protocols to get basketball back on the
court the standings were frozen in
mid-march with 16 teams in tentative
playoff positions they're only adding
eight more regular-season games so the
teams with the worst records their
seasons are over now six other teams
will have a chance to fight their way
into the playoffs the Toronto Raptors
with the third best record in the NBA
are guaranteed a playoff spot it's a big
step for sports during this pandemic but
for many in the NBA there is something
bigger than basketball right now the
death of George Floyd hit painfully
close to home for many players they know
firsthand the racial injustice that has
sparked demonstrations across America
I got a grandfather that marched next to
dr. King in the 60s
remembering history Malcolm Brogdon
marched with protesters so did jaylen
Brown and Steph Curry all recognized
that time has not brought equal justice
for african-americans we're talking
about hundreds of years of pain and
suffering for entire culture of people -
of basketballs greatest LeBron James
reposted from 2014 with the t-shirt I
can't breathe and Michael Jordan who
seldom speaks out issued a statement we
have had enough Atlanta's Trey young it
definitely is a brotherhood everybody
stay on that's what the NBA is in George
Floyd's hometown Minneapolis NBA players
so revered are using their voices to
call for change
I think it's important for me to be here
today because you know George Floyd is
me you know that could have been anybody
basketball is coming back and coming to
Disney World but for the tightly knit
NBA community this remains a sobering
moment to reflect on the racial
injustice that persists in America
Eric Sorensen Global News Toronto and
that is global national for this
Thursday I'm Donna Friesen tonight's
your Canada is this beautiful sunset
lighting up the water in Conception Bay
North Newfoundland and Labrador thanks
for watching bye bye
you